legendary
fashionable
powerful
[Music]
hi i'm
from geek culture hi kid and hi chloe
again how are you both good thank you
now
my first question is for kit welcome to
the mcu what was your initial reaction
to finding out that you're going to be
in a big marvel movie like the eternals
here's how i felt that you know you get
a call-off marvel and you have to sort
of temper your
initial excitement don't you because you
go every part of your brain is firing
off going so yes yes yes yes
say yes
uh
and then you go a minute who am i
playing
um and then you so i i was lucky in that
it was a conversation and it was a kind
of collaboration from the get-go with
initially with nate and then with chloe
and it was a chat about who the
character was and who he'd be in this
and based on that information you don't
necessarily get a full idea of a script
at first but you get an idea of the
character and where it could go
then i went yes yes yes yes please
were you a fan of the character like do
you know much about jane fitment or the
black knight in general i i wasn't a fan
of the character i had to look him up
but i once i saw what his thing was
uh and where it could go
i was like that
it's got a lot in it that could be
interesting to mine so this question's
for both chloe and kate where do you
think
uh jane could go like what are your
hopes for this character moving forward
like where do you see him
fitting into the wider mcu
go for it
well
if you haven't picked up
from the existing movie
when cersei and dane are talking on the
phone in the amazon and uh cersei is
saying go visit your uncle
and you always wanted to make a mess
names like my uncle no
and so he said go
and and so anyway the phone has off
well the other couple the next few days
when the world went is happening in our
movie
on the other side of the world dan is
thinking should i go see my uncle maybe
i should
and then he did
in my in my mind he did i mean that's
how i conceived this so then in the end
when you see him and cersei together
when he says
you know finally complicated and i think
he's found out something quite unique
now he's passed what's interesting about
all mcu
movies
especially with the the avengers the
four of them um
is this idea of plot going on in the
background
yes you're watching one movie but you
can link back to plot that happens in
that movie in another movie
and that's really clever and there's an
element of that that chloe's referring
to in this
um that could go somewhere i'd give one
last question now of course this movie
sees your kid reunite with your good old
pal richard madden what was it like to
share the screen with him once again
since you know 2013 that was like season
three of game of thrones you know what
it's never fun sharing the screen with
richard madden because um
slightly taller than me
uh he's got a much better jawline
um
and you know he's just charisma's coming
literally in this movie out of his eyes
so
um you know it's hard to go toe-stool
with him but he's a friend and i love
working with him and i hope we get a
longer
time on screen next time
thank you so much for the time
thank you
you